It's the one, the only, Katey Sagal, everyone.
(audience applauding)
Hello.
Okay, I have loved you for so long
and I was sitting at my kitchen table trying to eat
while reading your book and not being able to swallow
because I was so verklempt and I had cake in my throat.
I love your book so much.
Wow, thank you so much.
That's so nice.
I mean, this, I have been with this for some time now
and it's Mother's Day and we're talking about moms
and you just describe being a mother
in a way that I don't often read.
And I know as mothers we struggle for the words
to describe the indescribable.
Thank you.
Well, I was just gonna say the book started
as prose that I wanted to write for my children basically.
And it was just sort of snippets of my life.
And you sort of get to a place in your life
where you're like, oh I want them always,
I want them to remember.
I want them to know about me
and their lives and where they came from.
So it kind of was born out of that.
And lo and behold, it became a book,
but it was intended as sort of just for my kids.
It reads very poetically too.
There's, I know you're a rock and roll musician.
Music has been such an integral part of your life
and it has sort of a beatnik, poetic, one word sentences
and then you go down.
And I grew up obsessed with poetry
and I just thought there are no rules to writing.
You actually want your reader to read
the way it is in your mind.
And you just do such a beautiful job of it.
Thank you so much.
It was really a labor of love
and it was one of the hardest things I've ever done.
What I love about your book,
and this is the ultimate Mother's Day read,
is that we come into this world
with our own history with our moms.
And then we're just as moms trying to do the best we can,
not repeat patterns, break cycles.
And just the way that you spoke about your first daughter,
your oldest daughter was something I just hadn't read
because I felt so connected to you.
I'm so scared of whatever I'm doing,
especially with my first born daughter, Olive.
There's a different relationship there
than there is with Frankie.
The love is equal, but the karma is different.
And I just hadn't read anyone who kind of had the humor
without being best friend-y.
It was like, you talked about the role reversals
you go through as you grow up together.
Yes, we definitely do and you, and I find that
that role reversal has been as enlightening for me
as it is for her, as long as I kind of stay in step with it.
You know, I think that, I've always been really honest
with my children.
I have told them things that,
so that I've always wanted them to feel
and I have wanted, and they do,
that there's an open door, that they can always talk
to me about everything.
And because it's a big, wide scary world
out there sometimes.
So you want to be, and this was something I couldn't do
with my own parents.
I went through a lot of stuff that I just didn't feel safe
telling them about.
And I never wanted to, and I don't, I still don't,
I don't want to create that non place for them.
I want them to be able to have open conversation.
My thing with them is always like, look,
if you tell me the truth and it's something that
we don't like, it's better that you told me the truth.
You'll get in less trouble if you tell me the truth.
So that's kind of where I come from with it.
I'm so relieved to hear you say that
'cause I say the same things to my kids all the time.
And even if it's something I don't like, I will give it time
and then circle back to what we need to fix about that.
But in that moment, I'm like, let this secret be safe.
Let me be a safe place that's not gonna respond immediately
or judge or punish or anything.
I don't want to react, I just want to listen
and then we'll get there.
Don't worry, we'll get there.
Yeah, oh yeah, yeah, we get there.
We're going to deal with this.
And I'm so glad to hear you say that
and really this is a book that needs to be read by mothers.
It's, no matter what your experience with your own family
or what you're going through with your kids,
there is honesty, humor, and triumph in your perspective
that's very fresh and different than other books I've read.
Wow, Drew, this is so nice to hear you say all this
because I feel good about that book too.
It's been out for a couple of years, so thank you.
I really, really appreciate that.
(upbeat music)